I can tell you that what it takes to be
effective in python is pretty
straightforward
to be effective in Python that requires
a certain understanding of a couple of
core mental models of the language and
understanding of some of the things the
language comes with like the built-in
data types and the built-in functions a
little bit of an understanding of what's
available in the standard library this
talk however is focused on the next step
what does it take to be a little bit
better than just effective what does it
take to be good at Python or an expert
at Python now I could spend the next two
hours telling you in very philosophical
terms what that means and I could tell
you why
Python experts do things in one way or
the other we can even go very deeply
into some of the meaning behind the Zen
of Python but instead what I'd like to
show you more specifically is a couple
of what I call perhaps metaphors and
programming a Python it turns out that
as many of you know Python though it
originated as something of kind of a
scripting language does the convenience
language to patch together or to
orchestrate code that was written in C
to write simple scripts has since grown
into a full-fledged general-purpose
programming language and along the way
it's developed its own ways of thinking
about certain core constructs in
programming what I like to do in the
course of this session is show you four
features of Python and the ways that an
expert would think about these features
what I want to show you is not the
syntax of these features the purpose of
this presentation is not a feature
parade it irritates me on endlessly
whenever I see somebody who's writing a
book about advanced Python and the
entirety of the book is chapter one
here's a feature chapter two here's
another feature chapter three here's a
third feature and the entirety of the
discussion of these features is merely
its formal characteristics Oh a
generator has a yield instead of a
return
oh you can't send an on none value into
it just started generator a lot of
fundamental details of how these
features work but very little talk about
how we can conceptualize these features
in the broader sense of what they mean
for modeling core problems and so what
I'd like to do is I'd like to talk about
four of these features that you may have
seen before
and a couple of the core mental models
for how you can think about them and how
you can think about Python as a whole
and wrap all of these together one thing
that you'll notice is in addition to you
can probably hear them a little bit
stuffy a little bit sick that's only
going to exaggerate my inability to
remember the syntax or the documentation
for basically anything so you may see me
stumble but part of this presentation is
to see me stumble and to understand that
in cases where you don't understand or
you don't have the documentation
memorized or some of the corner cases
memorized what really is more important
for all of these features is an
understanding of what they are and what
they mean and not so much all of the
implementation details those
implementation details are of course
critically important when you're using a
feature but that's information that you
can look up and refresh when you're
actually in the middle of using that
feature itself before I get started I'd
like to take a small survey of small
informal survey of the audience so how
many of you here are Microsoft employees
almost everyone how many of you are
Microsoft employees that use Python as
part of your Microsoft work how many of
you are just Microsoft employees that
have seen Python used in various areas
of the company but don't really have
direct interaction with it yet how many
of you consider yourselves to be pretty
okay at Python how many of you consider
yourself to be really good at Python a
couple people how many people are
already in the back of the room thinking
I should be in the front of them giving
a talk myself maybe one person maybe one
person in the front okay maybe maybe
we'll have to show you something new
when it comes to those of you who've
seen Python how many of you feel like
you're pretty effective in Python I can
give you a simple problem you can write
some functions maybe even write a class
or two and you could solve the problem
without too much sweat is that most of
you how many of you are complete newbies
and you're like I have no idea how you
can get started with Python okay for
those of you who are complete newbies
you may struggle a little bit part of
this talk does presume a baseline of
understanding of Python however I don't
think that the core lessons that you'll
pick up here our lessons which will be
totally lost on you there are a couple
of core lessons which
even those of you who are somewhat
effective in Python already may yet have
internalized and we might we might have
a little bit of time to repeat those
what I want to start with is I'll start
with something really really really
basic and I'm gonna start a little bit
more basic than what I plan to just
because I thought the audience might be
a little bit more advanced of that so
what I'll talk about at the very
beginning is something that we might
call the data model now what you'll see
is I have all of the materials for this
prepared and memorized in my brain and
unfortunately my brain is getting older
and older as time goes on and so I've
already forgotten exactly what I want to
talk about and so you'll see a little
bit of roughness here but part of the
purpose of this presentation is to
present you with just the information
that matters without a lot of the
distracting details and so I will
actually rewrite all of my notes for
this as we go it's gonna be a little bit
rough but hopefully it'll be an
opportunity for us to focus just on what
really matters and for us to put aside a
lot of the associated implementation
details and things which frankly it
matters when you care about them but
it's not part of that core lesson of
understanding Python I want to start off
with something very simple
and you can see I created a directory
called data model and I'll just create a
simple file here I want to create a
class and we're gonna do all of this
everything in this course will be or
everything in this session will be in
Python three six it'll be in Python
three six just for my own convenience
just so that I don't have to worry about
all the details that might differ
between Python 2 and Python 3 there's no
particular reason why I choose Python 3
versus Python 2 for the purposes of what
I'm going to show you other than it's
the Python that I happen to use and it's
the Python that happens to be there's
some political reasons behind why Python
2 or 3 but even skipping that it's just
for my own convenience just to simplify
things so let's start with something
very simple I have some class I want to
do some kind of mathematical operation I
have some piece of software I write and
I have some class here that represents a
polynomial some
simple you know linear polynomial with
various coefficients and I want to
represent it as a Python object and so I
start with some code that looks like
this right class polynomial doesn't have
anything interesting it and I can create
two polynomials very simply
right and I might say p1 has
coefficients 1 2 & 3 right so this would
be x squared plus 2x plus 3 and p2 has
coefficients 3 4 & 3 so this would be 3x
squared whoops
plus 4x plus 3 okay and I want to be
able to do some simple things that we
did in math class with these I want to
be able to add them I want to be able to
subtract them I want to be able to you
know figure out some details of them the
very first thing for those of you were
relatively effective Python programmers
is you're gonna look at this I'm gonna
say why on earth did you write that in
four lines when he could have written it
in too light why did I write this in
four lines here when I could have
written it in two lines how would I
compact my code here so instead of
constructing my two polynomials and then
initializing the coefficients I could
initialize them all together what would
I do
I'm trying to get you to give me a
little bit of feedback here so what
would I do
what am I missing here my class has
nothing in its body what it's what isn't
missing to allow me to do this a little
bit more completely a little bit louder
for me I needed an it method and so the
very first thing when some of you look
at this is you say hold on you're
wasting our time here you probably want
to have internet method that looks
something like this so you can write
these lines much more hoarsely and you
don't have to have four lines when two
lines would do
all right so now we're happy
whoops
so now we're happy now if I rub my coat
and I'll split my screen shrink this a
little bit and I'll maybe print out
actually I'll do this so I'll run my
code and I have P 1 and P 2 and then
somebody else looks at this and says oh
my goodness print it out to the screen
that looks so ugly
what am I missing here missing another
method what am I missing
I'm missing a method that corresponds to
what happens when I call this function
at the top level repper to figure out
the representation of my Python object
yes or no yes so what method do i
implement up here
I have some method called repper right
so I have some method here that returns
a string that gives me the information
gives me a printable representation of
this class to the screen and so I'll
make this very easy like that and so
I'll run my code again and we'll see oh
there we go
those are our two polynomials pretty
straightforward and we could write we
could make this print out a little bit
prettier we could see the x squared and
the X and the constant term if we wanted
to but you can see this is a lot easier
than just seeing the name of the class
and it's memory location and we can
continue down this exercise because the
next thing I want to be able to do is I
want to be able to add these together
and when I add them together nothing
happens Python gives me an error
unsupported operand types 4 plus
polynomial polynomial but that doesn't
make any sense I know I can add
polynomials I did it all the time when I
was in high school how do I tell Python
how to add polynomials I have another
method called add and in my add method I
might return a brand new polynomial
where I just give it
all of course they're not cross ride
just zip together and add each of the
individual items so when I run that in
my script here p1 plus p2 it gives me a
polynomial with 4x squared plus 6x plus
6 now what's the pattern that we see
evolving here for those of you who are
off the top of your head you didn't you
didn't remember which of the underscore
functions there are for those of you who
haven't ever seen these underscore
functions before you've begun to see
some pattern and what is that pattern I
have some behavior that I want to
implement and I write some underscore
function some function that begins with
two underscores and ends with two
hundred scores and for those of you who
are Python programmers already you might
be familiar with these underscore
functions you might call them dunder
methods or double underscore methods or
if you find that word abhorrent as I do
you might call it by a different name
data model methods and you might say
it's an absolutely absurd thing to call
this data model methods that's so many
more syllables than dunder methods but
there's a reason I call them data model
methods which is I don't think I have
internet access but maybe I do oh I do
if you google for data model and Python
the very first or second link depending
on whether you use Bing Google or
DuckDuckGo will be a piece of
documentation here that tells you all of
these methods and what they do but the
pattern is a little bit more interesting
than that it's more than just having all
of these methods on a single piece of
documentation it is that whatever we
want to implement some behavior of
Python we want to tell Python for this
arbitrary object do this behavior give
me something that is a principle
representation for this object perform
some notion of addition for this object
we always see this common pattern and
the pattern is as follows
there is a top-level function or some
top-level syntax and there's a
corresponding underscore function the
exact arguments that underscore function
takes will be determined
by whatever you find on this
documentation page here the name the
default names of the arguments you can
pick up off this documentation here so
for ad I called it self another that's
just the conventional names for this the
what each of these actually do you can
read from the documentation but there's
something more fundamental here there's
a pattern what I want to add two objects
I implement ad when I want to initialize
an object I implement in it when I want
to tell Python what to do when you call
repper on an object I implement wrapper
we know in Python there's a function
called Len it gives you some notion of
the size of an object what would it make
sense for the size of a polynomial to be
what what might that know should be any
thoughts the degree right the highest
degree so we want to implement this
notion of size on this polynomial how do
we actually implement it what's the name
of the underscore function we have to
implement the one hint is there's
usually a very close correspondence here
so what would it be here Len if we
wanted the exact arguments that any of
the caveats for how this needs to be
implemented we could look at
documentation there isn't anything
special in the case of Len and we just
return something like land of
coefficients so this will tell us the
size of the polynomial in terms of its
degree and you can see these are both
degree three polynomial the pattern that
we see is as follows the Python data
model is a means by which you can
implement protocols those protocols have
some abstract meaning depending on the
optic itself in the case of a polynomial
to add them means whatever that meant a
math class in the case of a polynomial
to find its size means whatever that
would make sense for the case of a math
class so it may make sense for us to
know what the size this polynomial is in
terms of its highest degree to get its
representation
it's principal representation has
meaning that's given to us by the
documentation the representation of any
Python object is typically whatever
string we'd have to type at the console
to create another instance of that same
object and so on in each case this
protocol exists there is some underscore
method that implements that protocol
there are some top-level function like
Len or repper or some top-level syntax
like the plus sign or the multiplication
sign that allows us to invoke that
protocol and it all fits together in
this hole we can think of this as a
protocol in the sense that like many
protocols when we implement something
like Len we do that by delegating back
to the protocol itself
so notice Len is implemented in terms of
Len being called on a constituent object
ad is implemented by adding up some
components namely the coefficients
repper is implemented by calling wrapper
on some component we see this as a very
common pattern in the Python data model
every time we want to implement some
custom behavior on a Python object we do
it by implementing an underscore
function which ties to some top-level
syntax or some top-level function and we
implemented in terms of that thing
itself so for example if we have some
top-level syntax parentheses that coming
after the name of an object and we might
call that the call protocol we'd
implement it by implementing the
function called call we could look at
the documentation to see any caveats or
any special things we have to keep in
mind when we implement that in the case
of a polynomial this may not make a lot
of sense perhaps to call it means
something different maybe if we want to
have some really horrible syntax where
we say p1 p2 means multiplication we
could do that I can't think of anything
more ptosis than that but perhaps that's
what we what we want but in any case we
may implement this in terms of calling
something else this is one of the core
patterns that we see in Python
this is probably one of the very first
patterns that you'd see as a novice
Python programmer
in fact when you look at object
orientation of Python there are three
core patterns that you'd have to
understand to really understand object
orientation of Python this is one of
them
the protocol view of Python the second
one is the built-in inheritance protocol
and how it works where you go on a
Python object to look for things and the
third one is some caveats around how
object orientation of Python works
that's where I wanted to start off with
and for those of you who are just kind
of on that level of being effective in
Python these are the kind of patterns
that I would encourage you to look out
for as you learn Python
I want to go much deeper than this and I
want to jump into a very tricky metaphor
using a feature which you may have heard
of and you may have been warned against
something you may have seen kind of
along the margins when you're using some
library if you do anything with web
programming and you use Django you may
have seen this in the ORM or you may
have heard people whispering about this
one feature and I want to bring up this
feature for you I want to show you that
it has a very clear and concise meaning
just to illustrate how powerful these
mental models are for understanding
Python itself and for driving expertise
so let's shelve this for a second let's
show this idea of Python having a
protocol orientated data model and let's
look into a new feature I'll create a
new directory called meta classes
and we'll talk about meta classes for a
bit now the gist of this act this
tutorial is actually leading you towards
three features which are far more common
and far more interesting the meta
classes namely decorators generators and
context managers there is a reason I
want to start you off with meta classes
it's a feature that everybody is warned
against using they're told it's magical
it makes no sense it's totally the most
complicated thing in the world when in
reality it is the case of a feature
where if you understand what the feature
is really about it is very clear and
very obvious for why and when you use it
and you can it's something that you can
kind of shelve away in your mind as oh
this feature does this this is why I
want to use it I don't need to use it
all the time so let me show you what a
matter
class or what Mehta classes are really
about and I'll show this to you for an
example now here's an opportunity for
you to try something because I think
you'll really appreciate this example if
you try she let me do this in a
different way i braid up py so I have
two files here and I want you to
actually try this and I want you to
remember I want you to pretend that
there are two groups working on some one
piece of software one group is a core
infrastructure group and they write
library code and the other group is a
developer group and they write user code
the developer group takes the library
code somebody else wrote and they use
that library code to accomplish actual
business objectives the core
infrastructure group gets paid a lot of
money to accomplish no actual business
objectives but to provide library
software that the rest of us can use
isn't that the story of tech companies
which which team would you rather work
on nobody has any opinion whatsoever I'd
rather work on the user team because I
think that's where some of the more
exciting work is and you're a lot closer
where the money is actually being made
so that can't hurt but some people like
to be on the core infrastructure team
because they think that the technical
problems are often much more interesting
than some particular business units
problem around not getting data in the
right format or who knows well let's say
that this library provides classes and
these classes are expected to be
subclassed in the user code so I'll
create a class here called base and I'll
create a class here called derived that
derives from base
okay I've got five lines of code on the
screen this is the basic pattern we see
this pattern all over the place somebody
writes some class in library code and
somebody else has to use it I'm going to
add two things one function on each side
and then pose a question to you
let's pretend you exist on the
right-hand side of the screen you write
user code
you cannot write or alter or modify or
in any way
touch the code on the left-hand side of
the screen you can use it but you can't
change it it's library code you don't
have source code access to it even if
you did this is being deployed in some
environment where any local changes you
made wouldn't be preserved maybe in the
deployment environment this is pulled
down from NuGet or somewhere else so you
have no way to change the code on the
left-hand side of the screen your only
control is code that you can write on
the right hand side of the screen where
could the code on the right-hand side of
the screen break very simply
where could this function break if there
is no foo method exactly what can you do
in your code to make sure that at least
at the very minimum if the person who
writes a library code removes that foo
method your code fails not at runtime
but at any point earlier than runtime
one very simple thing you could do is
you could write a test that just calls
bar on your derived class very simple
thing and make sure you run your tests
before you deploy and you'll see the
code fail sometime before it hits the
run time production environment that's
one thing you can do anything simpler
you can think of take a minute and just
try and think is there anything simpler
you could add to this code to just make
sure that this code has the ability to
fail before it hits the run time
production environment doesn't have to
there's no there's not really that same
concept of compile time in Python as
there is in other languages but anything
you can think of where you could just
save yourself a little bit of effort if
those core infrastructure meatheads
accidentally screw something up and keep
you going you know I was I was on a team
iiiiii I often work in a vendor capacity
working on very small very narrowly
defined projects I was in a situation on
Monday where there was a sev one issue
and I was the only person on the team
that was thought to be involved with it
who was online somebody messaged me and
asked me can you help me with this f1
issue I told him I have no idea I work
on one tiny very small Python specific
very narrow area but apparently I was
the only one between between the manager
and the top of the company itself who
was online so I was sitting there just
kind of tell trying to tell people sorry
I don't know anything I'm hopeless let's
see if we can avoid those kind of issues
let's see if we can avoid there's
anything we could add to our code so
that you don't have to message me and
hear me complain to you that I don't
know anything and then you see how much
I billed per hour you're like well why
are we paying you so much if you don't
know anything what could you do any
thoughts I'll give you something really
easy real easy
oops
what is this different
what what's happening here here I check
to see that that method exists if the
method doesn't exist
I assert the code will fail so all I
have to do is make sure all of my
modules can be imported which does not
require a runtime environment I just
import everything if for some reason
they broke this this method here they
gave it a different name they called it
food instead I would see this code fail
before this class is ever defined and
I'd get exactly what I wanted I have
some early warning that this had broken
what we can see in general is that what
I'm trying to do here is enforce a
constraint I'm having the user level and
force some constraint on the library
level in other words the derived class
is enforcing a constraint on the base
class the drive class is saying hey the
base class has to have these
characteristics in order for me to run
and be happy and if it doesn't have
these characteristics in this particular
case if it doesn't have this method
implemented I'm gonna fail loudly and I
won't run so that's pretty
straightforward
actually that was
that was pretty straightforward and it
turns out there's quite a few different
ways we can do this
this little approach is very simple very
straightforward but let's flip the
script a little bit let's say instead we
have a case that looks like this
let's say now you're the core
infrastructure writer and you have to
deal with those meatheads in the
business unit actually using your code
and abusing your code and misusing your
code I have no idea what they're doing
and you write your base class under the
assumption that some responsible
developer in the business unit will go
and implement this bar method because if
they don't everything falls apart now in
this example you exist on the left-hand
side of the screen not on the right-hand
side of the screen you have no ability
to change the code on the right-hand
side of the screen even though you may
be higher up in the technical
organization you have no idea where this
right-hand user code even sits your only
ability is to put out library code for
people to consume you have no idea who's
even using your code you you even if you
could see their code you might not be
able to fix it let's ask a separate
question but a very similar question to
what we had before sitting on the left
hand side of the screen how do you make
sure that the user on the right-hand
side of the screen doesn't screw up how
do you make sure that in this case that
bar method is in fact implemented
because if it's not your code breaks and
they're gonna blame you they're gonna
call this foo method they're gonna see
in the trace back that foo meant that is
in your file and they're gonna blame you
for getting this wrong so how do you
work the other way how do you make sure
they don't screw up we can't do the same
thing we can't say assert has ADD or
derived bar this doesn't make sense on
the left hand side of the screen we'd
have to move that to the right-hand side
of the screen but we're not allowed to
touch the code on the right-hand side of
the screen so what do we do
any thoughts turns out there are about
three common answers to this one of them
is metaclasses there's two other answers
any thoughts where do we put the
try-catch we could do try here that
would be fine except this will only
occur at runtime so if we try catch here
it's not really any different than just
running this function and seeing the
error will still only see the error at
runtime we won't be able to catch it
before that code has production on July
3rd and they're calling me up to ask me
to help out and I'm like I have no clue
about they're like you're you're on a
team that's that's involved with as your
security and I'll say I have no clue
anything about agile security true story
really happens what can we do well if we
think about that very first example we
can see that our data model example
actually goes much deeper than just that
and the reason that we could call python
a protocol orientated language is not
just because the Python data model the
object model has protocol orientated but
that the entire Python language itself
has a notion of hooks and protocols and
safety valves within it I want to show
you something kind of interesting one
thing that a lot of people who come to
Python from other languages don't
realize is that Python is a much simpler
language than you might appreciate for
those of you who are originally C++ or
Java programmers you have a mental model
of your head in your head for how
programming languages like those work
and you have that mental model split
between some compiled time steps and
some run time steps and in that compile
time step there's an enormous amount of
complexity if you look at all the
different optimizations that the visual
studio compiler can perform on code
there's an enormous amount of complexity
there Python it turns out is a much much
simpler language Python code runs from
top to bottom linearly and almost
everything that you see in Python almost
every statement that you see in Python
with the exception of
two of them are actually executable
runtime code in C++ or Java a class
statement is not executable code in C++
it definitely is an executable code in
C++ a class statement just says here's a
bucket of bits here's how you named
portions of that bucket of bits in
Python a class statement is actually
runtime executable code what does that
mean well let's take a look what that
means is that in Python I could do
something like this define a class in a
loop 10 times in a row totally the most
useless thing I could ever do has no
effect whatsoever but I can stick for
loops outside of class bodies and
redefine classes if I want has no use
but it's it's meaningful in Python I can
do the same thing the other way
create a bar method under this foo
object ten times only one of them will
survive although the last one will call
all the previous ones but Python accepts
this as syntax because this class
statement is fundamentally executable
code and I told you and the direction
when we started this was talking about
Python as a protocol orientated language
let's see something kind of interesting
I'm just gonna create a function and
only need this for wrapping purposes let
me create my base class inside some
function and let me use a function and
in a module in the Python standard
library called dis dis stands for
disassemble let's disassemble this and
see what actually happens in a Python
bytecode what we see is something kind
of interesting we see that there's this
thing in the python byte code called
load build class it's an actual
executable runtime instruction in the
Python interpreter for creating a class
well hold on a second in the very first
example I showed you I said there
typically tends to be in Python some
correspondence between some top-level
syntax or function and some underscore
method that implements that syntax our
function there happens to be some
top-level mechanism here it's not
explicitly syntax it's not explicitly a
function for building a class it turns
out in Python there is a hook there is
an underscore function that allows you
to hook into and to do things with the
process of building classes and I bet
you can guess what it's called because
just like the correspondence between
repper and double underscore rapport
Len and double underscore Len adding and
double underscore add it's the same
thing here there's a function of Python
called build class it sits on a module
called the built-ins
so if I equals IPC so if I define a
function here called or to it like this
do I do this I'll capture the original
build class I'll write my own build
class I'll import from the built-ins and
I'll swap them out here I can patch into
what Python actually does when it
creates classes and I won't do anything
interesting in here I'll just print out
all the arguments that are passed okay
and so let's run our Python script one
more time
Python - I use her py oops and you can
see here's the class that was created in
fact you could even see I caught another
class that was being built I was
probably being built somewhere in the
interactive interpreter itself but the
most important one that you can see is I
actually can catch could actually catch
the building of this class and you can
see there's some interesting things that
I'm passed and passed the name of the
class and passed its basis and I'm
passed a function and I'm passed no
other arguments well what I can do now
that I can see the class that I'm
building is I could hook into this and I
could do something with it right I could
add my assert here I could say if the
actual arguments for this are and this
is where I can't remember them the
function the name and the basis function
the name and the basis and I could say
if the base actually it's the base if
the base is equal to this base here or
if it's actually this actual base object
I could check if the barmouth is defined
and when I run this you can see let's
pass in and kW here as well
what target mrs. take one - nope that
third one's optional because not
everything has to have a base class and
[Applause]
and who cares really this is a little
this one you can see I struggle with
this one a little bit cuz we never we
don't typically do this we say if base
is not none
okay there we go and you can see we were
able to have a little place where we
could check if that bar method was
defined this isn't typically what we do
but it's to show you this idea of Python
being a protocol orientated language is
actually quite a common pattern and
quite a fundamental piece of Python
almost everything that the Python
language does in an execution context
like building classes creating functions
importing modules you can find a way to
hook into that once you can find a way
to hook into that you can start doing
things that you want to do like check is
my user code going to break from the
perspective the library author now the
reason that I struggle with writing this
function here is in part because first
what's really the most important here is
understanding that this pattern exists
knowing that there are options for
solving this pattern and also knowing
that this is not the option that you'd
ever use for solving this better build
class is available for you to use but
it's not how people actually solve this
problem there are two fundamental
features in Python that people use to
solve the problem of enforcing
constraints from derived class to base
classes the first one is the metaclass
meta classes are merely
classes that derive from type that have
some special methods on them that you'll
have to read the documentation to
understand all the special methods for
but fundamentally allow you to intercept
the construction of derived types the
method that you care about here is
called new and it takes three or four
arguments basis body and the name basis
in the body and we'll see where it gives
us an opportunity to actually perform
our check
the basin's body
you can see it got called right here
with our derived class you can see this
last argument for the drive class is the
body of that class it's a dictionary
with all the methods of that class you
can see in it the bar method and so
simply to get the behavior I want I
could simply do assert bar or if not bar
in body raised type or her bad user just
like that this is the first answer to
the core question in order to enforce
the constraint the other way around if I
can only touch the code on the left hand
side of the screen and not the right
hand side of the screen I can't just
have assert lines all over the place I
have to do something fundamentally
different and the thing I have to do
fundamentally different is I have to
find a way to intercept how classes are
constructed of which there are three
common approaches build class which is
the least common approach but works on
the idea that Python is a protocol based
language has these safety valves and
hooks even in things as fundamental as
the construction of any class second
meta classes which are just the
mechanism by which classes are
constructed that's the approach that you
see here and I'll show you the third one
and third one is just a slight variant
on the metaclass approach when people
tell you about meta classes typically
they tell you this is a magical feature
you'll never need to use this feature
it's overly complicated and the reason
that I like to start this this session
with that despite its yes being a very
rare feature feature you'll very rarely
have to use it's to show you that every
feature of Python so far has at least
one or two very clear and unambiguous
mental models is applicable to one or
two very clear and unambiguous metaphors
for where it's actually useful in this
case meta classes or how you can make
sure that if you only control the code
on the left hand side of the screen you
can still enforce constraints on the
code on the right hand side of the
screen you can enforce constraints down
the class hierarchy from a base class to
a derived class
this is one approach using a metal clasp
that just intercepts the construction of
the clasp and the second is even easier
it turns out that in Python meta classes
are have a bad reputation because even
those people who understand where
they're useful see that meta classes
have a lot of complexity to them part of
what I haven't told you at all is any of
the syntax of the meta class or any of
the arguments they take or any of the
details for how the class hierarchy fits
together because all of that doesn't
really matter when you need to know that
information
you'll go look up and find that
information but unless you know why you
want to use them at a class in the first
place it doesn't matter how many details
of the feature you need to know once you
understand where and why you need to use
the feature then the rest of it are just
details you look up when you start
looking up those details you'll see that
in many of the features I show you the
story isn't that easy
there's always caveats there's always
catches and one of the catches is this
meta class feature is very clumsy to use
and so in Python 3 6 a new feature was
used or a new feature was added called
an it subclass and in its subclass I
think it goes here
it just gives you a method that allows
you to hook into when a subclass of some
classes being initialized and that's it
and I think it goes I think it goes here
let's find out if Brett were here you
could tell you exactly what goes
let's remove the metaclass for now
[Music]
I will do one thing if
always up there
okay so yes it got cold in the right
place and then it's a class okay yeah so
this gets called with the self so the
other approach we do is as follows
this was being called on that and with
the knit subclass we have other hooks
for figuring out
this one would come in a knit subclass I
have to remember what arguments it takes
but you can look into it really frankly
it does not matter that much so this is
my simple story about metaclasses
metaclass is our feature that were often
told that are an expert level feature
you're not supposed to ever use them you
should shy away from them you should
cover your eyes before you read code
that includes metaclasses
and it simply isn't that it simply is
that for all of these advanced features
there's usually one or two very clear
metaphors to understand what that
features all about and once you
understand what that figures all about
there's a lot of details you need to
read through a documentation that's the
approach I want to take for the
remaining three features I want to show
you the next feature is a very simple
feature called decorators I'm sure some
of you already seen this feature
but I want to show you kind of where
this feature comes from it's a very
simple and very boring feature indeed
and you've probably seen this feature
before it's this little act that shows
up on top of some function definition
this little app with the dotted name so
you see something like a dot B dot C and
for those of you who who are very
familiar with this feature you might
wonder why you can't do this or why
there are limitations to what you can
put in the decorator line the answer for
it is a really stupid answer there is no
good reason but there is a limitation
for those of you haven't seen this
feature before I want to show you
something about Python something very
core and very fundamental about Python I
told you when we talked about
metaclasses that python is a live
language there is no separate step that
turns function definitions into bags of
a set bits tagged and some elf binary or
some PE binary somewhere that a function
definition is actually a live thing it
actually runs at runtime there's
actually executable code associated with
this def F okay so let me show you that
in practice
here's a function called add that adds
two values okay let me create a little
separation down here and let me run that
and here I have my function add and I
can add two values now notice the first
thing I did in my terminal is I looked
at the function itself and I got a
return value you can see that the part
that interpret can actually tell me
where physically a memory this function
exists and in fact this add function is
an object and I can ask it all sorts of
things like what's your name what's your
module where you did where to find I can
ask it let's give that a default value
there and run this again I can say add
what are your defaults and it can tell
me what default values it had I can say
what's your code like what code do you
can do you contain this is actually the
byte codes for this add function and you
can see them right here
I could ask it things like how many
local variables do you have that's your
name there's one more that's interesting
for our names I can ask you what
variable names do you do interact with
one of the variable names of your
signature x and y and do all sorts of
things that interact live with this
function well it's interesting that this
function itself is a runtime object we
kind of see this or you might be
familiar with this if we're C or C++
programmers in C and C++ we can have
function pointers but they're really
just determined by the compiler they're
just memory addresses the compiler knows
for where it put the bag of bits that
represents that function sits in Java
for a Java programmer or a c-sharp
programmer we might be familiar with
runtime classes and functions under
those runtime classes and Python it's
closer to the latter but much simpler
than that every Python structure that
you interact with whether it's an object
or a function or a generator has some
runtime life has some runtime existence
you can see it in memory you can ask it
questions like what module were you I
did were you defined in you can even ask
it very useful questions like if you use
the inspect module you can say what's
your source code and it'll tell you the
source code right back out
so you can see you can ask the function
to give its source code it'll give you a
source code right back you can ask it
what file are you in and it'll tell you
what file it was to find it you can ask
it what module we defined in or I think
get line you can get get let's go what
line number it was defined on get ask it
all sorts of important questions well
there's something interesting that you
could also do let's say that I have some
code here that calls my add function
maybe it's part of some testing code or
maybe it's some code part of some
application
let's give it one more example so you
can see I'll add both numbers and also
add strings okay
simple enough let's say that I want to
change my code very slightly let's say
for some reason this add function isn't
quite doing what I want or maybe it's
doing what I want but I need to do
something like time how long it takes to
run because for some reason some of
these are much slower than other things
it takes a lot of time to run I want to
time it and so what are my options well
I know the time module there's a time
function so I know I can say time and I
can get the time right now when you do
that again I can subtract them and
figure out how many seconds it took and
so how would i time these I'd say before
equals time after equals time print time
taken after - before like this and now I
could kind of profile my code except
this kind of sucks because every time I
need to do this I need to add this in n
places throughout my code I have to add
in all sorts of places throughout my
code there's something missing here
there's something wrong here when we
look at this example and we think about
decorators in the context of the problem
we're trying to solve here we see
another core and important pattern in
Python the Python developers really
don't want you to be here today because
it's the 5th of July and they'd rather
you be home with your family spending
time with them I'm very happy that
you're here today in this session and I
hope you're enjoying yourself so far but
what I mean by saying the Python core
developers don't want you to be here is
this given the option between writing
and absolutely complete forward
compatible absolutely perfect solution
to a given problem and writing the
simplest stupidest quickest thing that
gets the job done the core developers or
the Python language would rather that
you write the simplest stupidest
quickest thing to get the job done and
go home and spend the rest of the day
with your family and the reason that you
know that that's true is that when you
look throughout the Python programming
language there are a number of examples
of cases where you can write the
simplest and stew
to get the job done and when the task at
hand becomes harder or more complex or
the requirements change you can change
your code in a very simple fashion to
linearly extend its functionality
without having to rewrite everything
from scratch this is a fundamental
difference between writing code and
python and writing code in a language
like C++ in C++ there is a lot of
upfront design that you need to do in
order to be effective and if you make a
mistake and something in your upfront
design in C++ you're gonna be rewriting
a lot of code down the line whereas in
Python we'll see a number of different
features are orientated around how we
write the simplest thing today and then
when the problem gets a little bit
harder we have an avenue for making our
code a little bit more complex here we
can see a bad example of that because in
the case where I want the code to be a
little bit more complex I wanted to
capture the timings for how long this
function took in addition to the
function output I've made my code
substantially more complex I've added a
lot of garbage and I've rewritten a lot
of stuff and you can think the ratio of
library code here to user code here it's
usually a lot more user code than
library code it's the whole point of
writing library code in the first place
and so to have
three times to have to have to add code
in three different places instead of one
place makes for something pretty pretty
gnarly so the first thing that you might
say is well I could add that code in
just one place I could say something
like this capture my return value and do
the time before and the time after print
it out here
like that and you you this would be
definitely better than before definitely
better than before I've added co2 one
place instead of three places but if my
library looked like this and maybe I had
examples my life my library looked like
that then I'm still really not in the
best situation because I have to add all
this tracking code to two places so it's
got to be a better way and in fact my
library could still be very big and so
that still means I have to write a lot
of code and rewrite a lot of code so it
must be a better way now remember what
did I tell you I told you that the pipe
that Python program language is a live
language that everything has some
runtime representation so both this add
function and this sub function have
runtime representations the sub doesn't
work on strings so both add and sub are
functions what can I do well maybe I
could write my own function called time
right or timer and I take a function and
I take the X and the y arguments and I
apply this function like that so pull it
off right and I do the timing before and
I do the timing after and I print the
elapsed time here
and I returned the return value okay
now I would just have to change these
lines of code slightly I have to change
that from a parenthesis to a comma and
so on as long as I could account for the
default value but I have to change each
one of these lines as follows it's a
little bit better not that much better
but a little bit better I'll change the
first three and we'll see it at work so
you can see from time to time let's make
this a little bit smaller so it all fits
on the screen at the same time and you
can see these three were timed the rest
weren't that's still not that much
better
I can still do better well remember that
everything happens live in the Python
programming language so couldn't I just
create a new function here couldn't I
define a new function here that takes
two arguments like this and in this
function do the timing call the function
that was passed in and return this
function here and you can see this here
is a wrapper that calls the function
that was passed in and wraps it with
some timing behavior before and after
and printing something out couldn't I do
that I can define functions at runtime I
can define functions anywhere and then
instead of all this nastiness changing
all this user code
I could just say ad equals timer of AD
and some equals timer of sub and you can
see it added that behavior across
everything and you can see what I do
that what I'm doing is I'm taking one
function I'm wrapping with some behavior
I'm taking one aspect or one piece of
core or common functionality and I'm
wrapping a bunch of different functions
in a really simple fashion and all I'm
doing is I'm creating a new function
that takes the original function and
wraps it with a little bit of behavior
before and after and that's it and it
turns out that Python wants to make this
a little bit easier for you because this
pattern of something equals call a
function on that original thing that
exists and that's what a decorator is in
Python a decorator is merely syntax
that's equivalent to the line that says
this sub equals timer of sub that's all
it is it's syntax that then fits into
the ability to dynamically construct a
function to wrap this behavior so this
is what our final example would look
like we would have started with code
that looked like this we would have had
to add only the timer code and then to
decorators and we'd be able to very
easily slip in this extra functionality
we want without having to rewrite all
this user code ourselves that's the core
of what a decorator in Python is at its
core it is very simple syntax to just
allow you to write an ugly pattern sub
equals timer of sub in a slightly nicer
way and a slightly nicer place at the
top but fundamentally it's about
allowing you to take this wrapping
behavior for functions and to wrap wide
swaths of functions in one fashion
without having to rewrite a lot of user
code or having to even perform a lot of
churn on your library code that's what a
decorator is go ahead
so one of the problems here I think
you're identifying here I hard-coded the
parameters right and I even hard-coded
the default the real answer is this is
where we use starts and start start
quarks
now this decorator works on any function
that takes any arbitrary set of
positional and keyword parameters and
just forwards the one and so now this
will work to wrap any function with any
set of defaults in any fashion this is
part of why starts and start start
quarks are so powerful they're there for
arbitrary for to write functions that
can take any arbitrary parameter spec
and forward it on in any fashion was
that was that the core of what you're
asking
[Music]
so you want to do something an N number
of times that's easy enough to so what
you want to do so say you want to have
the ad just run three times in a row and
you want to have the sub run twice in a
row what you do we'll take off the timer
decorator so we want to have some
function that runs end times right we
have our wrapper function in the middle
that takes any arguments here and here
and the question is how do we identify
how many times we're going to add one
more level to this what we'll say is
we'll say that n times gives you a
decorator so what let's let's actually
let's start this very simply let's
assume that we always want n times to be
twice okay we only want to run this
function twice so I'll say four I'll
just say n equals two here for da in
range of n are V equals function like
that
okay so here's our rapper they'll just
call a function twice capture the value
twice and return it and or turn our
rapper and then we can do we can apply
this here and here now we won't see this
really happen we won't see we won't see
the results here but if we wanted to you
could you could do this
so you can see it ran ad twice here ad
twice here sub twice there now you want
to generalize this because you don't
wanna run just two times you wanna run
at some number of times well why can't
we just wrap this another function that
takes the end and just return this like
that right so now this is a function
that takes how many times these are what
they call higher-order decorators really
not that interesting or that important
it's a fairly simplistic extension of
the idea
which is if you could return one if you
can have a function that returns a
function then you can have a function
that returns a function where that inner
function then returns another function
ad infinitum going as deep as you want
to solve whatever problem you want there
is a very important core concept that is
hidden in here which is what you might
call the closure object duality it's not
something that we have time to look at
in this session but it is a very
important duality in Python but it's not
one of the topics that we can look at
but just to show you this in practice
you can see this got called twice this
got called five times so you can write
your own end times decorator very easily
as well and the core of it is just the
idea that you start with the wrapper so
this is just a wrapper function what
you're replacing it with the decorator
syntax allows you to do that replacing
very easily and then in order to get
this programmatic behavior you just add
one level a function outside that
constructs the decorator
the decorator thing constructs the
wrapper the wrapper and then wraps the
function itself it is rare that you'll
see a decorator deeper than this just
because it's very rare that you have
context there's there's there's
typically not an additional context
where you need to feed information in
that requires you to have decorators
deeper than this so that's a decorator
decorators are probably the least
interesting of all the functions were
going look at or one of the features
were to look at the next feature I want
to look at is called generators now some
of you may already know what a generator
is
generators are very interesting and very
powerful feature of Python they're also
a feature that include where I feel that
mental model is often very limited what
people understand in the mental model is
often fairly limited there's more to it
than just what you might call the
eagerness versus laziness divide but let
me start you off with something more
fundamental than even that I told you
before that there's always some
top-level syntax or function and some
underscore method that implements it so
I told you if you have parentheses after
something this is what's called the call
protocol so there's some method call
that implements it I want you to tell me
what's the difference between this and
this
what's the Romans who add one and add
two
and I'll even create a terminal down
here and I'll add one adds two numbers
add two adds two numbers from the
outside what's the difference between
these two
you wouldn't unless you started peeking
inside unless you started saying what
are you add one well you're a function
what are you add two started started
peeking on the inside oh you're a class
wouldn't be able to tell the difference
functionally there's no way for you to
distinguish between the two in fact
add one behind the scenes looks very
similar to add two it's just that
syntactically
it's a whole hell of a lot easier to
write so from the perspective of
actually writing the code you're always
going to want our proof you're always
gonna want to you know do it this way
now there is a fundamental difference
which is if you wanted to start adding
some stateful behavior like this
right if you wanted to add that and
clearly there's one way to do it for add
for it for the adder and there's another
way to do it for the function it's one
way to do it for the class and we'll
wait here for the function and this is
the Afra mention when I hinted at this
object close your duality it's actually
a couple of different approaches you can
think of for how you do this
the core idea here is that fundamentally
there is some very nice syntax and then
some object model that everything kind
of sits in and this is closer to what
the object model itself looks like you
can think that ad 1 is some object that
kind of looks something like this
although we'll remove the statefulness
stuff just so that the two examples are
at parity let's think about this in a
different way let's think about some
function that takes a lot of time to do
something right maybe a function that
goes off and performs network requests
and it needs to load data from a
database
what would that function look like well
it might have their words the resulting
rows and it might say you know while DB
read rows dot append something now this
will be a little bit tricky for us to
actually demo so we'll do a couple of
simplifications just to make this code
look you know kind of mimic what
long-running computational code looks
like but without actually having to use
any fancy libraries so let's say what we
have instead it's we have some code and
it just sleeps for a half a second every
time it provides a return value and the
return value will just be a number from
0 to 9
let me ask you a question I will call
this our I'll just call this compute
[Music]
whoops what I call compute how long does
it take to run
five seconds what if I only care about
the first return value what if I only
care about the first value how long does
it take to run what if I care about the
first three values how long does it take
to run how much memory in terms of if we
if we just make very simple assumptions
how much memory does compute require 10
spaced 10 units of memory 10 integers in
a list right what if I only care about
the first time how much memory does use
same right what if I care about all the
elements how much memory does it use say
this is what we often mean by eager the
idea that this function irrespective of
what you actually care about in this
computation always takes the exact same
amount of memory and the exact same
amount of time it Gurley gives you the
entire result and you're sitting there
waiting for the entire result so you can
see it gives me the entire result all at
once this is undesirable because if this
happens to be not 0.5 seconds but 5
seconds then I have to wait 50 seconds
before I can even start processing the
very first entry and so I'm sitting
there blocked waiting for 50 seconds
when maybe I could process these one by
one also if this is not ten entries but
a million entries maybe only me to care
it maybe only want to look at them one
by one
I don't need to have the whole history
of all the entries I'm now spending
gigabytes of memory just so you can
equally give me the entire result set
what I only care to look at them one by
one and the moment I look at one of them
I could throw it away so you can see
this is both wasteful from the
perspective of the time that it takes
and wasteful from the perspective of the
amount of memory it takes let's think if
there's a better way to do this and
let's think about this in terms of our
object model let me rewrite compute as a
class
so it doesn't take any arguments and
I'll just dump this stuff underneath
nothing very interesting here but more
or less does the exact same thing really
no difference between the two versions
so I haven't gained anything here I
haven't gained anything by seeing into
my object model that said I've kind of
seen this pattern before I've seen this
pattern of I only want one element at a
time and I'm going to get each element
and as I get each element I'll process
it and maybe throw it away it's a basic
looping construct in fact I see it even
here in this looping construct here I
don't get the entire list of once I only
get each one individual element of the
list and one thing that we might know is
that in Python we see top-level syntax
or top-level functions has some
corresponding underscore methods that
implement it if I told you that there's
a pattern there's some if I told you
that there's some syntax for X and XS
and I told you that this syntax actually
looks like this
more or less under the covers
you could probably guess what the
underscore functions we have to
implement would be they had correspond
to these two top-level functions here
and here they'd be in ER and they'd be
next so what that means is we can take a
class in Python we can add an inner and
a next method and suddenly that class
can be iterated over well in the process
of that iteration what could we do well
anything arbitrarily including perform a
long computation so what we could do and
what the inner method actually needs to
return you'll find out when you read the
documentation it's not that important
will just return self the next method
just gives you each next method that you
iterate over well instead of putting the
computation in this eager call method
what if I did this what if I have the
inner method say the last number I
looked at was zero and I do this
hey so soft outlast plus equals one if
self stopped last is greater than and
will limit this loop back to ten just to
keep our live sane it's greater than 10
raise up iteration
otherwise we sleep for 0.5 seconds and
we return self dot last and we'll
actually do this will be slightly
different so we'll do it like this
sure
so there this will give us the same
thing so now it's slightly different
order but you can see now our next
method computes what was the last value
we looked at captures it it increments
the last value we looked at if there's
too many it raises to stop iteration we
won't worry about what that means just
yet it'll sleep corresponding to our
long-running computation and or return
the value now notice something different
between this compute method and this
next method this compute method returned
a list of all the values this next
method returned a single value and the
way that you'd use it is as follows
you just print it out you loop over and
print it out and we'll actually see that
here in practice you can see it's
computing each value one at a time and
in this loop here you can do something
you want with it like print it out it
still takes 50 seconds to total to print
out the whole thing but you only pay for
or still takes 5 seconds of totals to
print out the whole thing but you only
have to pay for one unit of computation
before you can start using that value
and it no longer requires 10 units of
memory because there's no storage
anymore notice here there's no storage
and here there's no list there's no
storage well this really looks ugly and
this is really hard to read just like
this looks really ugly and this is
really hard to read and there's a much
simpler way to write it a much simpler
formal expression for how to write
functions there's a much simpler way to
write a function it operates in this
fashion and that's what the generators
in Texas that generator syntax is merely
something that looks like this
and all this means is this thing here
compute is something that can be
iterated over each time you iterate over
it this is the value that it will yield
the stop iteration naturally happens
because if you try and iterate over this
too many times there'll be nothing left
to yield because you'll have fallen off
the end of this block here it's state is
maintained internally it's just a
function that kind of doesn't really
return eagerly you'd never want to write
this formulation this is just such a
pain in the butt
you'd instead want to take the original
function formulation and write it in its
generator formulation when you look at
the function formulation in the
generator formulation and you squint
your eyes you can see all the same
pieces in the same places except in one
of them you have storage and you have
eagerly eager computation of the entire
result set and then the other one you
have no storage and you're simply
returning values as you see them this is
the core concept behind it generator and
the core mental model behind a generator
that instead of eagerly computing values
you give them to the user as they ask
for them but there is another similarly
important and critical core concept to
how generators work beyond just this and
that's what I want to show you leading
up into our last example we have all
seen API to look like this run this
first
we've all seen api's that look like this
which have methods that indicate the
order which you have to run functions if
you don't run this first first
everything blows up if you don't run
this last last everything blows up and
in the documentation they tell you
please run this method then this method
then this method because if you do it in
any other order all hell breaks loose
unfortunately this API is kind of lying
to you because nothing stops you from
being a dunderhead so i don't like the
word dunder and doing this nothing
physically stops you from putting these
in the wrong order other than that you
failed to read the documentation and
you'll see a break well one interesting
thing about the generator formulation is
that if you look at the generator
formulation you can see it performs some
computation then not only does it yield
the result back but it also yields
control back to the caller you can see
here in this formulation it's lowercase
this I perform one computation while in
the long-running computation modeled by
this sleep and then I give the value
back to the user to do something with
and then they ask for the next
computation give it back to the user to
do something with so I'm kind of
interleaving the user code in the
library code in the eager formulation
the library code ran to completion gave
the entire result sent back to the user
then the user did whatever they want
with it in the generator formulation I
have a little bit of library code run a
little bit of user code run then a
little bit of library code run and over
the user code run and I interleave them
this is the actual core
conceptualization behind what the
generators are built upon the idea of
co-routines
subroutines we can think of as any piece
of executable code that runs from some
starting point to some ending point to
completion they have they have one
single entry way and they have sorry
they have one single entry point and
they have one single exit point and
that's it they run they're done if you
look at how user code a library code
interact if the subroutine is in library
code it runs the completion
the user code has to pickup for the
generator or the co-routine you enter
the generator and as you asked for
values the generator runs but you can
have this nice interleaving where some
user user code runs ask the generator
for a value the generator runs its code
yields back to the user code the user
code does whatever at once it goes back
to the generator astronaut of al you and
so on so you have this interleaving of
the two pieces of your code the user
code and the library code here in this
API what we actually have is similarly
when we use this API we'd ideally want
to have some interleaving because we we
would if we could run all three of these
methods all at the same time the API
would never have provided as three
methods if we didn't have to have some
code between these three calls they
would never be provided as different
calls if they could all be done at once
we just have one method here called do
it that just calls first second and last
and make sure that we can't screw this
up so the reason that the API gives us
these three pieces put into three parts
is it because I specifically intend us
to interleave code they just want to
make sure we interleave code in a fixed
sequencing in a fixed order well let's
think about this if I wrote this as a
generator we could do that interleaving
while maintaining the sequencing and
this I would say is maybe even a more
critical mental model for generators
than this eager list eager versus lazy
divided the idea that generators are a
mechanism by which you can create code
that can interleave with other code and
also enforce sequencing notice here that
what happens when this generator runs is
it'll run up to this point yield no
value but allele control back to the
caller then the caller can resume and
the caller can resume in this particular
formulation first second and last will
always run in that order you can't
guarantee the last two run but you never
can guarantee that someone could pull
the plug before that runs
but here if the API were provided in
this fashion you could guarantee that
the last method was never called before
the first of the second method the
generator forces that sequencing on you
and it forces that sequencing on you
because the generator is ultimately a KO
routine that allows you this
interleaving between two types of code
user code and library code let's
remember that and we'll go into the
final of the examples we want to look at
the context manager
context managers are a very very simple
metaphor and a common metaphor you see
all over the place if you're a C++ user
you've seen this metaphor before you've
probably called it resource allocation
is initialization or something like that
if you're a Java programmer you've seen
this metaphor before but I don't know
what you call it in Java I don't know if
Java has a real name or concept for this
it's the idea that there's always some
desire to do some setup and teardown and
then you want to combine them if you're
a Python programmer and you've done even
very introductory stuff with Python
you've seen a context manager before and
it looks something like this it's the
most basic context manager that you've
seen before you open some file and the
reason use a context manager here is
that there's some corresponding setup
and teardown if you open the file you
got to close the file this is especially
true on Windows because on Linux file
locks are a little bit less aggressive
on Windows if you don't close the file
you might not be able to delete it later
this is especially true if perhaps this
file is backed by some storage where
it's not necessarily automatically
flushed if there's some IO buffering
because definitely if you open the file
and you're right to it you want to make
sure those are flushed to disk in case
the program terminates at some point
with unflushed io buffers you might lose
things that you intend it to be written
to disk but fundamentally there is this
metaphor here this idea that we have
some set up action and some teardown
action some initial action and some
final action and we want to match them
together let me show you an example of
that
it goes beyond files but it can go even
into things like SQLite databases so in
SQL in in SQLite we have these these
file back databases the connect method
is actually a context manager itself
so here I connected some database I have
some cursor on that database and let me
just do this and I could do some
statement so I could do something like
create table points X into y int create
so I have some statement to execute a
table maybe insert some things into this
table
X Y values 1 1
here we go and then I have some
statement where I could select for this
there we go
and then we could commit this so here we
have just a very simple use of a context
manager wrapping some database
operations and what is it's not corrupt
to commit we don't need that actually
and what we'll do is we also want to
make sure that we drop our table when
we're done there we go
until you can see the code ran I'll do
two selects just so you can see
everything you can see our code ran now
you can see that the idea of there being
some setup and teardown action it's
pretty clear with the opening and
closing of the database right obviously
if we open the database and we write to
it we want to close it but there's
another setup and teardown action that
you might not see here see if you can
spot it if we assumed that we did
something and we want to have some
corresponding action to undo it what's
the what's the pair that you see here
yeah I create a table and I drop a table
now naturally if we were to really
properly do this we'd probably do it in
a transaction and the transaction would
give us the right semantics but let's
assume that for SQLite we might not have
transactional support so we have to be
in charge of that parent that create and
that drop and naturally it's a very very
natural pairing you create something you
drop it you want to make sure that both
of them get done irrespective of some
error pops up in the middle so how do we
actually write our own context manager
and you'll see that this will bring
together everything we've looked at so
far as I told you it turns out
fundamentally in Python there is always
some top-level syntax or some function
and some underscore methods that
implement it if I told you
let's write it like this GX as X if I
told you that behind the scenes this
actually looks like the falling x equals
c TX enter try finally
if I told you that and I don't know what
the Ark there's some arguments that
capacitor I don't care what they are but
if I told you that's what it looks like
you even know exactly what the
underscore methods are they're right in
front of your face right and turn exit
so that's how we write a context manager
we implement and turn exit now here
you're gonna see me really fumble
because I don't remember any of the
arguments that get passed there let's
try this so we're gonna create a temp
table context manager and we know we
need to implement enter and exit right
and this takes some other arguments and
I don't really care what they are and we
know maybe this temp table needs to take
you know just for this thing to work
we'll need to initialize it with a
cursor okay and then the enter just
execute this statement and the exit just
execute that statement except this is
self dot cursor and this is self dot
cursor and that's it we have some enter
code and some exit code and I just move
things around to fit it into the
protocol and then the next thing I do is
I just had these over and I say with
temp table curry calls with that cursor
fair enough
there we go
so let's see that in play seem to work
let's run that again it seemed to work
let's run that again seemed to work if
the table weren't destroyed then I would
get an error there saying table already
exists so clearly the enter and the exit
being called I can even show you that
more explicitly this seems really really
uninteresting so where's he going with
this I wonder see there's the enter the
exit pretty straightforward
now I wonder why I brought this one up
because context managers have such a
clear unambiguous metaphor behind them
why would I take almost you know a third
or a fourth of our time to talk about
context managers watch do you see
something kind of interesting here kind
of interesting here can the exit be
called before the enter should it nope
so the enter should always be called
before the exit right what does that
tell you there's some sequencing where
does that suggest to you generator
because we just saw generators or about
sequencing maybe I can improve this
example by using a generator because
here you can see there's an enter and
exit the answer has to be called before
the exit there's some sequencing
necessarily that two generators are all
about so let's do it like this
let's move this up here let's move this
down up here we'll put it yield in
between the two and here we'll just say
temp table we'll call this a context
manager almost a temp table self dot
cursor will create an instance of this
and then we'll just do next
self dot gen I think that'll work and
then we turn itself
oh wait to do context manager
we have two another next in here and
then we have to just do one tiny thing
here that doesn't really matter that
much so there we go we see everything
still work so we'll put our we'll put
our little enter and exit print
statements just to see them still
running enter up here or watch you make
this a little bit better we'll say
created table
drop it's a table just add our little
locking statements in there just so we
can see them in our car create a table
drop table so we can see how this
conceptualization of generators as
sequencing is very useful now this is
not sufficiently general for my purposes
because you can see I kind of hard code
what the generator is so let me just do
this I'll just have it initialize what I
want the generator
what generator I want to use the enter
notice I can I have a callable function
here so what I'll do is I'll just add in
a call here so I can get some arguments
which will be the cursor or maybe the
args and the quarks
I just capture those on the enter I'll
call my generator with the arguments
that I was passed and I'll get my
generator instance and I'll forward it
here and here so now I can say context
manager of temp table I can call the
cursor there and then I have something
that'll work
now let's see if that works
and then this asset return itself and
then this should be self kwargs okay
there we go so we can see this still
works now you might wonder why did I go
through all this effort well I want to
show you something kind of interesting
this line here looks really ugly so here
why don't I just do this just move my
code around a little bit take that line
here and I'll just say temp table equals
context manager of temp table you can
see what I kind of did was I took my
generator and I wrapped it in some
object that just kind of fit eaten the
parts of the generator to the enter in
the exit right that's all I did and now
I can just say with temp table of course
sir right this will kind of probably
seen this like a couple minutes ago
never saw that pattern before yeah I've
seen something like that anyone seen
some really useful Python syntax so you
don't have to write that
you take some object that happens to be
a function you pass it to another thing
that gives you something else and that
rebind zit anyone seen this too nice
before I can tap back to the panel it's
only two back what is it well would what
we do here why would we not write this
because we have a simpler syntax what we
write easier here anybody decorator so
you can see it works without the
decorator but we'd probably just write
this like that
right oops
it still works well it turns out all
this garbage up here we don't have to
write it's already been written for us
it's in a library called context Lib and
it's just a decorator the terms it's
just a decorator that turns a generator
into a context manager and the only
things that we need to make this work
completely is that here in this example
I want to show you something this is an
example that combines three core
features of Python together generators
context managers and decorators it
doesn't requiring that you know a little
bit of the details of how each of these
work but fundamentally what we can see
is what we have here is three features
with very clear conceptual meaning
orthogonal conceptual meaning where each
of those pieces of conceptual meaning
kind of fit together a context manager
is merely some piece of code that pairs
setup and teardown actions so that the
teardown action always occurs if the set
up action occurred a generator is merely
some form of syntax that allows us to do
things like enforce sequencing and
interleaving notice the context manager
requires interleaving because the setup
is interleaved with the actual action
you do in the block you do the setup
then the action in the block then the
teardown at the end there is that
sequencing where the set up the enter
has to be done before the exit so it
makes sense to have a generator here as
well
finally we need something to adapt the
generator to this data model that we
looked at at the very beginning we have
these underscore methods and we have to
find some way to take how the generator
works and fit it into those underscore
methods one of the things we need to do
in order to do that is we need to take
this generator object and wrap it in
some fashion that wrapping is part of
the core of how Python works it's easy
to dynamically construct functions and
have those functions wrap other
functions that's part of the core
language itself it's not really
something that we could even lift the
level of being a feature it really is
core to how Python itself is written
however there does happen to be a
feature called decorators that allows us
a nice convenient syntax for doing that
exactly so what you can see here is an
example of everything except metaclasses
and how they all fit together and how
some of these core pieces of Python fit
together to write what you might
consider to be more nearly expert level
code what I can tell you is that in
Python expert level code is not code
that uses every single feature it's in
fact not code that even uses that many
features of Python its code that has a
certain clarity to where and when a
feature should be used it's code that
doesn't waste the time of the person
who's writing it because they say to
themselves I have this pattern Python
has this mechanism I fit them together
and everything just seamlessly and and
and very smoothly works it's code that
doesn't have a lot of additional
mechanisms associated with it it doesn't
have people creating their own protocols
it doesn't have people creating their
own frameworks where the language itself
provides the core pieces that you need
and you merely have to understand what
those core pieces are what they mean and
how to assemble them so over the last 90
minutes I've shown you a couple of
details of how Python itself is designed
and for features that you've probably
heard of that python is known for for
features that you might associate with
features that an expert would know or at
least if you go an interview for a
Python job and you say I'm an expert
Python programmer these are four
features that you're going to be asked
about more likely the question here is
does anybody remember any of the syntax
they looked at probably not even I don't
remember it and I'm giving the talk and
I have cheat I have notes here I have
like a cheat sheet
the real answer here is the notes the
the details they do matter they matter
very much you can't write the code
unless you know the syntax the code
won't won't compile it won't run however
what is far more important and then the
names of the arguments that get pass to
exit or the specific fashion in which
different numeric underscore methods get
dispatched whether you do our ad or our
ad depending on which is the most
derived class all of those details are
actually secondary to a core conceptual
understanding of what these feature mean
what these features mean so what I can
tell you as the real lessons from this
session or as follows Python is a
language orientated around protocols
there's some behavior some syntax some
bytecode or some top-level function and
there's a way for you to tell Python how
to implement that on an arbitrary object
via underscore methods that exact
correspondence is usually guessable but
if you can't guess it
Google Python data model and you'll find
all the different methods and all of the
caveats of their use Python is a very
simple simplistic language in terms of
his execution model code runs from top
to bottom and things which would not be
executable statements and other
languages like class statements and
function definitions or general
definitions are actually executable code
in Python because they're executable
code not only can you do things like
hook into them but you can also do
things like define functions within
functions based off of runtime data
define classes within functions based
off of some runtime information you have
how these impact specific features
metaclasses metaclass is merely some
hook into a class construction process
because classes are constructed at
runtime you can hook code in there and
because you can hook into the creation
of subclasses you can ask the subclass
certain questions like
do you have these methods simply do you
have these methods implemented that's
what they do that's the mechanism but
the meaning behind it is quite simple
you have library code and user code when
you sit on the library author side how
do you make sure the users don't screw
up how do you enforce a good straight
from the library code to the user code
well all that it takes is some way talk
into the process of how user code user
classes are instantiated that's merely
what the metaclass is you find that
place where you add that hook you add
the check that you want Oh make sure
that you have the bar method implemented
and you solve the problem in fact in the
Python standard library there are
regularize solutions to problems like
that in collections that ABC there is an
ABC meta class it allows you to use
decorators to mark certain methods and
abstract methods so you don't have to
write them at a class yourself and you
could think this is a pattern of what
the meta class is doing in fact almost
every example of a meta class that
you'll see will be this pattern of some
base class and some derived class the
base class trying to enforce a
constraint on the derived class it's
almost every pattern of the meta class
that you'll see where that meta class is
it justified of course you can misuse
them to do all sorts of crazy things you
can use them in places where it doesn't
make any sense but in the justified uses
of the meta class that's what it's all
about for the decorator it really isn't
anything that interesting just a little
bit of syntax to allow you to write one
line of code a little bit nicer to take
one line of code that you'd write after
your function definition and put it
above your function definition but it
hooks into this idea in Python that
everything gets constructor at runtime
so that when you combine that with the
ability to define functions within
functions you can use this in order to
wrap sets of functions with some before
and after behavior if you're have been
around long enough you might think you
might recall this was the whole aspect
orientated idea but the idea that can I
take a function and wrap it with some
behavior such as timing you know
capturing the time before and capture
the time after or doing things like
authentication or logging anything where
you don't have to go into the function
itself you just wrap the behavior around
generators are merely a way to take a
single computation that would otherwise
run eagerly from the insert from the
injection of its parameters to the final
computation and interleaving with other
code by adding yield points where you
can yield the tech the intermediate
result values or one small piece of the
computation and also yield control back
to the caller in that vein you can think
of a generator as being a way to take
one long piece of one long computation
and break it up in small parts where the
computation can run a small sub subunit
of that computation that your user code
can step in and do whatever it wants
maybe it will use a partial value or use
one of the first return values if you're
returning a sequence of return values it
might use the each of the individual
values and in that fashion you could
have greater control over how much of
that how much of that computation
actually runs do you run it all the way
to completion or the only need to run it
to gab the first five values you need
you also have greater control over how
much memory is used because the
generator can just yield the values back
to you and you can choose which of those
return values you want to keep which of
them you want to throw away context
managers are merely some structure for
allowing you to tie two actions together
a set up action and a teardown action
and make sure they always happen in
concordance with each other if the set
up action occurs make sure that teardown
action occurs even if some error happens
in the middle and when you think about
these features and you realize they're
related but mostly orthogonal you can
combine them in interesting ways like
you see in this example here where you
have a decorator a context manager and a
generator all coexisting and serving
exactly it's one purpose as I said at
the very beginning the syntax doesn't
matter the details won't matter until
you need to use them what I want to
leave you with especially since a lot of
you are not already very fluent Python
programmers I want to leave you with
this idea remember what these features
are about remember what they're for
that's something that you should be able
to remember longer than the exact
details of the syntax or evil implement
implementation details in fact the
implementation
the details of the syntax will change
over time some of the flaws in the
implementation may get fixed other
details will be fixed another fashion
but the core meaning behind these is
something that will last and will guide
you towards writing expert level Python
code far better than memorizing just a
bunch of features ever will so that's my
presentation I hope you enjoyed it thank
you very much for being a part of it any
questions in the back a little louder
please
yeah and can I use like when I use yield
it basically continues to do the earlier
processing yes so so the idea is what
you've what you've immediately jumped on
is this idea that you can interleave
what you've I think it jumped on to is
the idea that well while I'm well I've
returned control back to the calling
context can I have the original context
keep keep working please look in any
kind of sit in the background and do
some work and then by the time I go back
to the generator I can go and ask it for
some value it doesn't have to do
anything cuz it's already in the
background done that well yes you can
you could have the generator start its
own thread and maybe do things at its
own thread that's entirely possible
and that wouldn't be part of the
generator syntax itself the generator
itself is not intended for interleaving
in a concurrency mindset and so where
you see generators used as part of this
broader idea of concurrency and Python
is that the generator mechanism and its
syntax have been further refined in
Python 3 6 2 this asynchronous
co-routine syntax there are many reasons
why strictly simultaneous running Python
code is something that has been avoided
for a very long time at Python
you must have heard of the global
interpreter lock and some limitations of
the global interpreter lock accepting
that as a limitation the approaches that
people take in concurrency in Python
when they mean single in process
concurrency are typically either threads
and they ignore the global interpreter
lock or they just allow for strict
interleaving of code where you know it's
all single process so it's all single
threaded one thread one one greenlit
sleeps while the other one runs and you
don't have strictly concurrently running
greenland's that's closer to your answer
which is generally no the generator is
not for this kind of multi-threaded
equivalent approach it really is for
this one runs then this one runs and
this one runs this orleans and that's
considered to be the preferred approach
for concurrency in python where the
concurrency is i/o bound yeah
so you are referring to the runtime
chicks versus otherwise yeah so what
would be the other what would be the
point in time the other asserts or
validations would happen so the problem
is runtime checks require you to have
the code deployed in a runtime
environment so you'll never know the
problem until you hit that exact code
path the whole point of this is can we
any sooner than when it hits that code
path in deployment in a deployed
environment catch the error any kind of
run because Python doesn't have a very
strong compiler has a very small very
that compiler doesn't really do a lot
it's gonna be very difficult however
what we can think of is that module
import time is an equivalent to compile
time and Python so just being able to
import a module is something that we can
do before we hit the run time compile
context we can do it at our laptop and
if the module imports normally then we
can say okay this code will be safe in
production all of the checks that we
looked at there or checks which we can
run by just sitting at our laptop
importing all of our modules if it
worked
we'd say good to go another thing that
we could do is maybe run a unit test
suite but that might be one level deeper
than these checks because you can think
the unit test suite is gonna take a lot
longer to run and it might have some
mocking of data and moving things around
so we might have is some checks in the
file itself import everything okay good
to go then run our unit tests okay good
to go
deploy to production and then hope that
somebody's online who knows how to solve
the problem when something breaks quick
follow up on the unit subclasses that
still run time or is it's a they're all
they're all there in its subclass is a
runtime check but everything that runs
at the module level is run at runtime
it's just that there are different
runtime scopes in Python so in its
subclass will operate in the same
fashion as the metaclass it'll merely
just another place that you can hook
into the initialization of a subclass
and you have to look into the details I
thought it took different arguments than
it does you'll have to look into the
details to see what what arguments it
takes
and how you actually use it for the for
this purpose
because there's a lot of these details
of these features unless you're really
hopefully you're never you're not
somebody who's constantly using them and
unless you're constantly using them the
details are things that are easy to
forget but if you know where to look or
you know what to look for those are
details that you can very quickly pick
up and frankly and it's the class has
only been around since 3.6 a lot of
these details do change over time but
the core models the core mental models
have not changed since these features
were first introduced even the extension
of generators for co-routines and for
asynchronous programming the core mental
models behind it haven't really changed
since they were first introduced in
python 2 6 2 whatever any last questions
ok well I hope you enjoyed the session